>> Lawrence: BRET, THAT'S THREE
EXTRA SECONDS FOR ME.
>> Bret: THAT'S RIGHT.
THERE YOU GO.
>> Lawrence: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "FOX NEWS PRIMETIME."
♪
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING ME AND I'M LAWRENCE
JONES.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES.
TOMORROW MARKS THE ONE YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD.
AMERICAN COMPANIES DID THEIR
BEST TO PROVE HOW COMMITTED THEY
WERE TO DIVERSITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
COMPANIES PROMISING MONEY LEFT
AND RIGHT AFTER FLOYD'S DEATH.
$50 BILLION IN FACT WAS PLEDGED
TO ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S BILLION WITH A B.
SOME OF IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
DONATED TO CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS.
INVESTED IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, OR PUT TO A REIMAGINING
HIRING PRACTICES AT MAJOR
CORPORATIONS.
AND NOW A YEAR LATER, HOW MUCH
DO YOU THINK WAS ACTUALLY SPENT?
TAKE A MINUTE AND GUESS?
80%?
ABOUT 50?
25?
WHAT ABOUT IF I TOLD YOU THAT
ONLY HALF OF 1%, $250 MILLION
WAS ACTUALLY SPENT BY THESE
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT OF BLACK
LIVES.
I BET YOU WILL THINK THEIR
HOLIER THAN THOU PLEDGES OF.
BLACK COMMUNITIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS WERE NEVER GOING
TO GET THE SUPPORT THEY WERE
PROMISED.
BUT YOU WOULD BE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE ONE GROUP THAT MANAGE DID
GET A WHOLE BOAT LOAD OF CASH
WAS BLACK LIVES MATTER.
THEY PULLED IN MORE THAN
$90 MILLION LAST YEAR.
BUT ONLY MANAGED TO SPEND A
QUARTER OF IT ON CHARITABLE
CAUSES.
THEY HAVE BEEN SO SHADY WITH THE
MONEY BEGGED THE GROUP TO STOP
PROFITING OFF HER SON'S DEATH
THAT PROBABLY EXPLAINS WHY,
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," LOOK AT THIS, PUBLIC
SUPPORT OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
HAS CRATERED SINCE JUNE 20TH.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS IS
FOUNDER OF BLACK GUNS MATTER.
MAJ, YOU ALWAYS TELL IT LIKE IT
IS.
SO WHY IS THE SUPPORT DROPPING?
>> THE SUPPORT IS DROPPING
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING
THE MONEY.
A BUNCH OF THE MONEY, DARREN
SEALES TOLD US BEFORE HE WAS
MURDERED BLACK LIVES MATTER
INCORPORATED IS A SHAM
ORGANIZATION DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO FLEECE THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH IMPROVING THE CONDITIONS OF
BLACK AMERICA AND OPS.
PERIOD.
>> Lawrence: MAJ, THE
ORGANIZATION, AND PEOPLE ON THE
STREET CALLS FOR JUSTICE.
YOU HAVE THE ORGANIZATION ALL
THE DOUGH MAKING ALL THESE
PROMISES BECAUSE THEY WERE
PRESSURED TOE DO SO.
WHEN IT CAME DOWN TO THE NITTY
GRITTY, THE COMMUNITY DIDN'T SEE
A LOT OF THAT THE QUESTION IS
WILL THERE BE BICYCLES FOR
CORPORATIONS OR WILL THERE BE
PRESSURE TO PAY UP BECAUSE I
WANT TO SEE THE DOUGH.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T WANT THE BOYCOTT.
THE BLACK COMMUNITY WANTS THE
MONEY.
YOU SAID THAT MOPE WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
YOU SAID IT YOU PLASTERED THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER -- LET ME GO
BACK A SECOND.
YES, WE KNOW THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER AS A REALITY.
OBVIOUSLY.
RIGHT?
AND SOME PEOPLE IN AMERICA WANT
TO PRETEND LIKE THAT WASN'T THE
CASE.
I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE PEOPLE
DOING LEGITIMATE COMMUNITY WORK
AND THE INC. THAT FUNNELED.
THIS WAS A MONEY LAUNDERING
SCHEME.
IF I AS BLACK GUNS MATTER WE
RAISED AND GAVE AWAY OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS WE DO WORK IN
FIREARMS SAFETY AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND CONFLICT
RESOLUTION IN BLACK COMMUNITIES
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
WE HAVE RAISED $410,000 GIVE OR
TAKE AND I HAVE BEEN VERY
TRANSPARENT WITH THE MONEY.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF I'M AT
CONSERVATIVE TABLES, CAN YOU
IMAGINE HAD YOU THEY WOULD HAVE
CRUCIFIED ME IF I ONLY SPENT A
QUARTER OF THAT $400,000, A
QUARTER, 25% OF IT ON THE STATED
PURPOSE?
NO, IT WAS A MONEY LAUNDERING
SCHEME AND A WHOLE BUNCH OF THAT
MONEY, DON'T WANT TO GET ANYBODY
IN TROUBLE BUT, YES, I DO.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF THAT MONEY WAS
FUNNELED TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND JOE BIDEN AND HIS TEAM'S
WHOLE SCENARIO.
THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY IS AT.
FOLLOW THE PAPER.
THAT'S WHY THE PLUMMET HAS
HAPPENED AMONGST THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
YOU SEE IT.
>> Lawrence: YOU GOT THAT
ASPECT.
THEN YOU HAVE THE OTHER ASPECT
OF THEM SAYING, LOOK, WE ARE
GOING TO HIRE MORE BLACK FOLKS
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT MORE JOBS,
BUSINESSES THERE, DO THE WORK,
YOU KNOW, NOT JUST CROPS.
WE ARE GOING TO PUT BIG BUSINESS
IN THESE COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HIRE BLACK PEOPLE.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN EITHER.
>> THIS FROM THE SAME GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT PAID TO DESTROY THE
BUSINESSES IN THEM SAME
COMMUNITIES.
MY COMMUNITY.
THEY BUSTED A GANG OF PEOPLE
THAT WASN'T FROM THERE
INCORPORATED.
NOT THE PEOPLE THAT LIVED THERE
WE HAVE SEEN SCORES OF PEOPLE
OVER THE LAST YEAR STOPPING
PEOPLE FROM DOING THINGS IN
COMMUNITIES SAYING HEY, YOU
DON'T LIVE HERE, WE ARE HERE
ABOUT A PEACEFUL ASSEMBLY.
WE ARE HERE ABOUT A PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
PEOPLE GETTING BUSSED IN WITH A
LOT OF MONEY THAT CAME FROM
SOMEWHERE THAT DESTROYED THOSE
BUSINESSES IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THIS IS A LET ME CREATE THE
PROBLEM.
LET ME PRESENT A SOLUTION SO YOU
DON'T RUN TO ME AS YOUR SAVIOR,
BLACK LIVES MATTER INCORPORATED.
NOT THE PEOPLE NOT THE RANK AND
FILE PEOPLE DOING THE WORK.
BLACK LIVES MATTER INCORPORATED
IS A MONEY LAUNDERING SCHEME AND
THEY BETTER GET THAT BRAND
RIGHT.
>> Lawrence: HERE'S THE RUB.
THE COMMUNITY KNOWS THIS.
THE COMMUNITY HAS BEEN GOING
AFTER BLACK LIVES MATTER FOR A
WHILE.
WE ARE -- WE ARE NOT SUPPORTING
THE ORGANIZATION.
WE WANT EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE
LAW.
THE COMMUNITY KNOWS.
THIS THEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING BACK
AGAINST THAT NAME AFTER NAME.
BREONNA TAYLOR AND THAT MERE
RICE'S FAMILY.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY VOCAL ABOUT
THIS.
THE QUESTION IS WHO IS GIVING
THE MONEY TO THESE GROUPS?
ARE THEY WHITE LIBERAL?
BLACK AMERICA IS ALREADY HAVING
THE CONVERSATION.
SO WHO IS TRYING TO FEEL GOOD?
>> THE HONORABLE SHALL
AL-SHABAAB MALCOLM X SAID THE
WHITE LIBERAL IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS THING TO THE BLACK
AMERICAN EVER.
WHITE LIBERALS ARE BEHIND AND
FUNDING THIS ANTIFAMILY,
ANTINUCLEAR FAMILY UNIT,
ANTI-STRONG FATHER IN THE
HOUSEHOLD MOVEMENT THAT HAS BEEN
MORPHED INTO SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN VERY DETRIMENTAL FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
IF YOU WANT TO TELL ME THAT, YOU
KNOW, HEY, WE'RE GOING TO BE
HELPING YOU BUT WE HAVE TO
CONTROL ALL OF THE MONEY, WE
HAVE TO FUNNEL IT THROUGH ACT
BLUE.
I QUESTION YOU, THE MONEY WILL
MAKE A MAN CHANGE GODS.
IF WE KEEP FOLLOW THAT MONEY WE
WILL SEE ALL OF THE WHITE
LIBERALS AND A SPRINKLING OF
SOME OF THE BLACK FOLKS THAT
BOUGHT MILLION DOLLARS HOMES OFF
SOME OF THAT BREAD WE ARE GOING
TO SEE THAT THAT AIN'T FOR THE
HOOD NO MORE.
IF YOU WANT TO SUPPORT SOMETHING
SUPPORT BLACK GUNS MATTER.
WE ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE SAY WE
ARE GOING TO DO WITH THE MONEY.
>> Lawrence: WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP FOLLOWING THAT I LIKE
LOOKING AT THE RECEIPT AND SEE
WHO PAID UP AND MAJ I KNOW YOU
DO, TOO.
I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU JOINE